or moi oui c'était venu comment
limitation sinistre culture française
ouais si il ya beaucoup de trucs comme
ça je savais qu'une petite nana
peut-être qu'elle regarde d'ailleurs je
mets beaucoup beaucoup
et pendant que je joue au rugby j'ai
appris qu'à cet effet un musicien de bal
je me suis dit [ __ ]
s'il faut monter sur une scène pour ce
faire des nanas 1 eh ben je vais faire
l'imitateur j'ai coiffé mon bep raymond
machin est tout et j'ai fait ça en fait
part par revanche entre rencontre la
motivation
celui qui imite le mieux c'est qu'ils
mois encore par jour dans tout en
réserve je regrette de ne pas savoir
éviter c'est le billet de 500 balles et
je pense que le plus fidèle ça doit être
pour vivre plus fidèles parce que je
suis capable de parler pendant 3h 4h en
tambours vive mais j'ai de la tendresse
pour de funès un peu puis tu sais
maintenant je dois en avoir je pas de
sens et s'ils n'étaient jamais arrivés
il était au plein il a plein qui coûte
cher
l'inimitable bricaire si on si le coq le
fait terriblement et c'est vraiment bien
non il y en a plein parce que dans la
configuration de ma voix est parfaite
pour et puis il ya des gonzesses que
j'arrive pas illimité parce que parce
que je ne lis pas facilement dans la
peau des nanars de quoi ranimer mais
t'as combien de d'imitation c'est parce
que jamais comptés parce que maintenant
j'ai deux catégories j'ai les imitations
que je sais faire vocalement c'est à
dire je vais avoir deux sens et cakes
salés tronche les épiler tronche c'est
après ça que c'est de mettre devant
unités devant une glace de maquiller te
retrouver avec la tronche de noter à
monture garde qu'il y assez de long le
baril au départ et ben [ __ ] c'est à
dire
justement côté avec france soir tu lui
fais rambo des fois non jamais boeschèpe
à ohrid second est sûre je planque pour
être pas mais fernandel dans le noir
c'est affolant et qui timide bien toi le
coq mini pas mal gré ouais j'aime bien
moi j'habite en rajout qui fait mal le
cas contre intimité ou plutôt ses
géniales ça fait bien il 6 tient de
c'est vrai que j'avais un petit qu'à un
moment j'ai toujours la main la basse et
du mental maintenant occuper seul nom du
ponteil attrape son pantalon comme c'est
bizarre oui ça doit être une race de
mecs le sac qui ont cure qu'elle s'en
aille mais c'est pas parce qu'elle est
percée qu'il faut qu'on a je dis moi le
coq ça va avec lui là parce qu'il a dit
que tu es fait dire et de tf1 quand même
ah voilà immonde connerie mais je sais
pas mais là au point j'aime pas la
polémique mais je vais pas balancer tu
veux vraiment quand le mettre au point
moi je veux bien mais j'ai jamais fait
dans la vie qu'on parlait pas télé non
mais attends j'ai jamais alors il ya un
truc qui est clair c'est que j'ai jamais
fait virer le col de tf1 au contraire
même s'il ya de plus embêtant c'est
qu'il le sait c'est qu'il sait que j'ai
insisté pour qu'ils restent
et qu'après il a répondu le bruit que
j'avais fait virer ça sympa ça c'est
alors t1 mais le bon t'as un mec qui
timide bien c'est celle au cac
est ce que tu sais que tu as un sosie
oui oui je connais danseuses et ouais je
suis une limite bien souvent boire je
suis désolé parce que il faudrait bosser
avec moi je sais pas comment tu vois
maintenant il ya un an il m'en veux un
peu parce que je je je je le fais pas
bosser avec moi mais je vois là je vois
pas la solution comprend l'intérêt
surtout nous le prêt de 16 nous on a
fait baisser
on a fait bosser il lutte conte la télé
poubelle sur non